in the wilds of upstate new york
the catskill mountains dominate the
western horizon
they are cloaked in green maple ash and
oak stand shoulder to shoulder in dense
forests that drape across the hillsides
and at the mountain's feet a small
clearing is little more than a gray scar
in the flesh of this
verdant landscape
but this scar is a tiny window on
another time
on another long lost forest
[Music]
the clearing is a sandstone quarry once
the source of building stone for the
nearby towns
all stand silent now abandoned save the
birdsong
and the rustling leaves
today used for little more than off-road
vehicle stunts
but in 2019 paleontologists made an
extraordinary discovery
[Music]
etched into the flat quarry floor is an
intricate
radial structure
branching out from a single central
point dendritic arms extend for many
meters
at first glance it seems as though
lightning has struck the grey rock
scorching its forked pattern into stone
itself
but this is no lightning strike
they are the fossilized roots of immense
and
unimaginably ancient trees
[Music]
here tucked beneath the roots of the
modern day catskill forest
are the roots of the very first forest
on earth
[Music]
the rocks that contain these remarkable
fossils are an astonishing
385ml years old
[Music]
dating to the late devonian period
[Music]
and during that primordial epoch large
animal life
was still largely confined to the oceans
[Music]
the land surfaces however are overrun
with green plants
and primitive insects that crawl burrow
and flutter amongst the foliage
on this green new world for the very
first time
a battle for vegetal dominance drives
plants to ever greater heights
they are desperate for the life-giving
light of the sun
[Music]
but in constant conflict with their
neighbors always threatening to cast
them into shadow
[Music]
it was this eternal arms race that gave
rise to the very
first trees
we know them as archaeopterus different
from the ones we know today
but not so different to be
[Music]
unrecognizable
with woody roots and branches they
evolved to stand proudly up to 10 meters
tall
breaking free of the jumbled green
battleground of horsetails and ferns
beneath
they were the giants of this world
[Music]
and so the quarry floor the foot of the
catskill mountains
preserves some of the earliest days of
the age of trees
[Music]
the fossil roots are those of
archeopterius reaching out
probing for water in elite devonian soil
as no plants had done before
[Music]
in the hundreds of millions of years
since time has turned the ancient forest
floor to stone
yet nevertheless those first trees have
left their mark here
just as they left their mark on our
[Music]
world
[Music]
once this evolutionary arms race for
light had led to trees some 385 million
years ago
they proved to be an especially
successful adaptation
soon spreading to every corner of the
world
and in fact it was a perfect time in
earth's history for colonization
and expansion
the perennial forces of continental
drift having brought the disparate land
masses together
to forge a single supercontinent
pangaea
[Music]
where they collided continental puzzle
pieces crumpled at the edges
lifting great mountain chains into
existence
the catskills themselves an extension of
the appalachians
already loomed over the landscapes as
the earliest forests spread
from pole to pole
it was a warm wet time with high sea
levels drowning shorelines
creating shallow seas and vast tracks of
swampy land
this was the setting in which the first
forests found their feet
innovated and succeeded
huge trees grow up to 35 metres tall
reproducing with spores like ferns do
today
at their feet the understory still
bustled with hardy colonizers
leggy horsetails bristled wherever the
dappled light breached through to the
forest floor
trees and plants put down roots probing
deep into the ground in search of water
and anchorage
through biological action the land
surface
was shattered weathered more than ever
[Music]
before
the dominion of trees also set the stage
for animal life
to finally make its decisive move onto
land
[Music]
tetrapods took their first tentative
steps out of the ocean
overshadowed by the trees that had
already made it their home
insects thrived in this verdant
playground
diversifying into new and bizarre forms
specialized for living among the many in
various types of plant they rely on for
food and shelter
in an increasingly vertical ecosystem
flight becomes a new necessity
and the insects spread their wings
with the vast supercontinent covered by
forest the photosynthetic engine is
pumping at full speed
drawing in carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and replacing it with oxygen
this reactive gas is no longer poisonous
to life on earth
it's been a constant companion for one
and a half billion years
and life is now utterly reliant on it
[Music]
and as the global forests thrived oxygen
levels soared
to levels 50 percent higher than today
with excess oxygen in the air oxygen
breathers
thrive too giant insects dragonflies and
centipedes
far larger than today now fluttered and
crawled through the endless forest
swamps
[Music]
for 60 million years
trees ruled the earth
their dominion is immortalized in the
name of an entire geological period
the carboniferous
so named for the huge swathes of
carbon-bearing rock left behind
when the great forests died
[Music]
rocks that fuel our world today
and all of this was made possible by
photosynthesis
using light as energy an unexpected
chemical innovation
deep in life's microbial past
but just how much of our modern world is
shaped by photosynthesis
and what might the planet look like had
it never
evolved at all
[Music]
some hundred or more light years away
from earth
a rocky planet orbits a yellow star
[Music]
on it intelligent life has evolved
[Music]
great civilizations have risen collapsed
and risen again
spawning immense advances in culture
arts
society and increasingly
[Music]
technology
they surround themselves with technology
[Music]
and as they strive to understand
themselves naturally
they seek an understanding of their
place in the universe
[Music]
at the very height of their
technological revolution they build
elaborate scientific instruments
launching them on rockets into orbit
around their star
[Music]
these alien telescopes position
themselves in the shadow of the home
planet
shielding themselves from the glow of
the star allowing an unpolluted view
of the night sky
[Music]
with unprecedented precision the
telescopes examine the light from each
distant sun
looking for a characteristic dip in
brightness which portrays another planet
another solar system just like their own
[Music]
but their instruments can see far more
than that
as a planet passes in front of its sun
some of the starlight will pass through
the tiny sliver of atmosphere
at the planet's edge
[Music]
by analyzing the spectrum of visible and
infrared light from that sliver
these curious scientists can reconstruct
the composition of distant atmospheres
[Music]
so as they train their telescopes and
our sun
another yellow star like their own
they are confronted with a planet a
world which dims the star
every 365 days
in its sliver of atmosphere they see
nitrogen water vapor
a little carbon dioxide and oxygen
[Laughter]
[Music]
the discovery doesn't just make the
extraterrestrial news
its reverberations alter the very course
of their history
[Music]
for life has been discovered beyond
their solar system
[Music]
they are not alone
[Music]
for these aliens know the significance
of oxygen in an atmosphere
such a reactive gas can't linger in any
great quantity unless it's been
constantly refreshed
and they know no other way of generating
oxygen than life itself
[Music]
no inanimate planetary process could be
responsible
only the process of photosynthesis
is able to make so much oxygen so
reliably
[Music]
using light to split carbon dioxide and
water to capture energy for life
[Music]
even from trillions of kilometers away
this planet our planet screams
photosynthesis and life
our entire atmosphere seen from space is
a product of plant
life whether this is intelligent or not
remains to be seen
if an interstellar expedition were to be
launched from this hypothetical alien
world
no matter how long it would take
scientists on board
or reading the data from home would be
able to confirm their theories as soon
as they were close enough to take a
picture of the planet
just a few pixels would reveal that in
addition
to the blue and white of a watery world
the earth is trimmed
with green
compared with the other lifeless worlds
of our solar system
coloured red gray or white by the rocks
and ice exposed at the surface
the earth is swaddled with life
and that life is green
and on earth that green has been a
fundamental part of our history
during the early 14th century genuine's
mapmaker pietro vesconti
made a name for himself in the maritime
city-state of venice
[Music]
creating maps of the mediterranean and
black seas
his nautical charts were among the most
advanced and accurate of the day
using compass bearings and sailing
directions from ports and harbours
to precisely reconstruct the shape of
the coastline
[Music]
so in 1321 when approached by a venetian
statesman to produce maps for a new
manuscript
he knew that something special was
called for
[Music]
this manuscript would be used to
encourage a new crusade
to the holy land as ever
war being the great motivator for our
species
not only did these maps need to be
accurate but they needed to be
beautiful and compelling too visconti
spared no expense
and so it is visconti's mapamondai
his map of the medieval european world
that impresses with its vivid green
coloration
to this day it is unique for the time in
its accuracy
and its realism one of the most
impressive early attempts to define the
borders and contours
of our world
[Music]
subsequent map makers have copied the
shape of the world onto paper
pouring carefully over the shape of
kingdoms and continents
but unwaveringly the colors remain the
same
blue for the oceans green for land
green is the color of photosynthesis and
it's become the colour of the land
too it's the colour we as humans
instinctively link to nature
to healthy growing landscapes
[Music]
it's the green pigment in plants that
powers photosynthesis
and it's photosynthesis that powers all
life on earth
but photosynthesis powers even more than
life
it powers industry too
since its emergence in single-celled
bacteria more than two billion years ago
photosynthesis has transformed not only
the surface of the planet
but also the rocks that form underground
the oxygen pumped into the atmosphere
rusted the proterozoic land surface
turning sediments red and producing
brand new
oxidized minerals never before seen on
the planet
and as photosynthesizing plants came
into their own
the sheer quantity of organic carbon
captured began to leave its mark
ordinarily plants that die are recycled
as part of the great circle of life
animals insects and microbes go to work
stripping
energy-rich organic molecules from a
vegetable carcass
but sometimes conditions conspire to
spare a dead tree
plant or algal bloom from the scavengers
perhaps they are swept away in a flood
or buried by a sudden volcanic ash fall
or drop through the ocean depths to
anoxic waters where no life can survive
if plant life is buried undecayed
then its carbon is committed to the
rocks
time heat and pressure transform it and
tectonic movements
may eventually bring it back to the
surface
about 50 million years ago the same
tectonic forces that pushed up the alps
to the south
also uplifted layers of carboniferous
carbon-bearing rocks in the middle of
england
subsequent erosion exposed the thickest
coal seam in europe
that turned the very ground black across
an area of about 36 000 hectares
this became known as the black country
and in the late 18th century it was the
very epicenter
of the industrial revolution
many consider the boundaries of the
black country to be defined exclusively
by where the 30-foot coal seam breached
the surface
certainly it was the abundance and
accessibility of the coal here that
secured the black country's importance
in the growing
industrial world
visitors would come to describe the
region as black by day
and read by night as every scrap of land
was claimed for collieries
furnaces foundries and factories
chimneys belched smoke through the night
and a spectacular new industrial future
dawned this was where the first
successful steam engine was built
where the first bridge made entirely of
iron was constructed
the black country transformed britain
into the world's
furnace
the industrial revolution was the
beginning of a new era for humankind
the industrialization of our world paved
the way for mass production
and the technological advancements at a
terrifying pace
none of this would have been possible
without subterranean coal
and other fossil fuel deposits worldwide
and none of those deposits would even
exist
without plants their crushed ancient
remains
fueling the furnaces of industry
it was the invention of photosynthesis
in bacteria
billions of years ago that made our
modern technological lives
possible
from the composition of the land and sky
to the staggering diversity and
achievements of life
photosynthesis has utterly completely
transformed the
earth a single chemical reaction
involving mere atoms and electrons
became so successful that it was written
large over billions of years
and eventually had the power to modify
an
entire planet
but what would the earth look like if
this
unique biological engine had never
arisen
[Music]
evolution is blind new innovations arise
by chance and if they help an organism
succeed
they will persist into future
generations
photosynthesis was just one such chance
innovation
and a different role of the evolutionary
dice could have plotted a very different
future
for our planet and the life that grew
here
a world without photosynthesis would be
a world without technology
without industry without green on the
land and in the sea
without oxygen in the atmosphere and
almost certainly
without humanity to try and understand
it all
without photosynthesis to precipitate
the great oxygenation event
more than two billion years ago the
archaean oceans and atmosphere
would persist just as they had already
persisted for billions of years before
levels of carbon dioxide and methane in
the atmosphere would stay high
continuing to swaddle the earth in a
thick insulating blanket of greenhouse
gases
[Music]
icy poles and mountain peaks would
become a thing of the past
as the temperature of the entire planet
crept up
and this would be a roiling humid heat
as water vapor drawn from vast world
spanning oceans
fed towering thunderclouds
storms would rage around the planet's
circumference
whipped into swirling cyclones that feed
on the hot surface waters and hurl their
energies at those barren land surfaces
that have the misfortune to lie in their
path
[Music]
as millions of years pass this heating
only worsens
the faint young sun once barely burning
hot enough to keep the planet's ocean's
liquid
has begun to mature nuclear fusion in
its core
builds up heat and the warmth that the
earth receives from its
nearest star inches up year
on year
with a thick atmospheric blanket of
carbon dioxide methane and water vapor
this added heat is swallowed and kept
close
earth teeters on the edge of the runaway
greenhouse warming
that baked its neighbor venus to death
but our world lies some 40 million
kilometers
further from the sun it retains its
oceans and the planet's hot core
churns on oblivious to the heating on
the surface
volcanoes erupt tectonic plates shuffle
and life
clings on in the archaean oceans
life survived quite happily before the
invention of photosynthesis
instead of feasting on the sun's energy
these chemosynthetic bacteria turn their
attentions to the ground
and the mineral energy contained within
had this remained the only option for
life then two billion years of evolution
would produce a very different biosphere
to the one we now inhabit
in 1986 when communist surveyors in the
southeastern corner of romania
began investigating a potential building
site for a new power plant
they made an extraordinary discovery
as they measured the strength of the
gravity across the flat featureless
planes
their instruments spoke of a massive
void
several meters below the surface
that quite simply shouldn't have been
there
[Music]
the ground was unbroken hiding any
indication of a cave beneath
but as they tunneled vertically down
they found a vast
clay-lined cavern system that extended
hundreds of meters into the pitch
darkness
these caves had been shut off from the
outside world for more than
five million years without a glimmer of
light
to penetrate the gloom
and yet in the total subterranean
darkness
life thrived
small blind insects and other
invertebrates crawled
slithered and swam through the black
pools
busying themselves with the basic
motions of existence
survival reproduction and finding food
the nutrition at the base of all food
chains in this isolated cave was not
created with the energy of the sun
but rather the energy of the earth
itself
microbial chemosynthesizers not so far
removed from their archaean cousins
seized every opportunity to feast on
whatever chemical energy they could find
sulfur compounds methane and ammonium
became potent inorganic energy sources
for these resourceful bacteria
they colonized the water's surface in
thick films or cling to the cave walls
and ceilings
held together by sticky extracellular
glue
and by transforming their mineral food
sources they capture the energy they
need
and expel their waste products to
accumulate in the airtight cavern
here carbon dioxide levels soar to 100
times the concentration of the air
outside
the air smells of rotten eggs and burned
rubber and the water
sizzles with sulfuric acid
but to the chemosynthesizers and the
animals that eat them
this is the only home they've ever known
this pitch-black poisonous cave in
romania is a tiny window
into a world without photosynthesis
in an alternate present where bacteria
never learned to eat the sun
they instead become breathtakingly
proficient at eating
the earth
so from their modest beginnings around
volcanic vents in the deep ocean
chemosynthetic microbes spread and
evolve
learning to survive off the meager
pickings of less energetic minerals
with the help of their extracellular
glue and their waste products
microbial forms begin to shape the world
both beneath the ocean surface and on
land
[Music]
waste sulfuric acid eats away at the
ground carving out huge gorgeous
and plunging cave systems in all but the
most resistant of rocks
chemosynthesizers relish in the new rock
surfaces exposed by the chemical
corrosion
and follow the water and mineral food
into the depths of the crust
instead of vertical forests of trees
reaching for the skies
there would be plunging dark forests of
microbial stalactites
in fractal biological caves
light or dark these microbes do not care
as long as there is fresh chemistry
within reach
and yet the chemical energy in the earth
is limited
minerals run out and waste products
accumulate
until these chemical factories are
starved and smothered
into submission food chains and
ecosystems of more
complex life could evolve to rely on the
chemosynthesizers
but since the energy is limited the
abundance and complexity of these higher
forms is also curtailed
they are smaller slower and less
abundant than the animals we
share our photosynthetic ecosystem with
[Music]
and there are no mighty apex predators
or sentient
sapient equivalents
only grazers crawling among the weeds of
a slimy
colorless chemosynthetic world
indeed this is a diminished existence
over two billion years ago a roll of the
evolutionary dice gave us photosynthesis
a different role could have secured a
very different fate for the planet
and for life
but these dice are weighted many
researchers believe that photosynthesis
is inevitable on a world like our own
just as it is on an alien world given
the same chemical circumstances
[Music]
although life can use the bounty of a
planet to power its biological engines
the mere fact that this fuel is
exhaustible
destined to run out someday means that
there is a very real
pressure to seek out an alternative
and like the pre-photosynthetic
bacterium of the archaea in the world
for us today sunlight is the ideal
alternative
[Music]
readily and endlessly available on the
surface of every
terrestrial planet
[Music]
on our world and on others like it
finding a way to use that light might be
the only way
for life to survive in the long run at
all
and searching for the signs of
photosynthesis on a planet
oxygen in an atmosphere or a smear of
green across the land
or carbon locked away in its rocks may
be the best way
we can hope to find life elsewhere
in the universe
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth don't forget to like and
subscribe
and let us know what you think in the
[Music]
comments
[Music]
our writer leila batterson has released
a video to coincide with this one
investigating the detection of oxygen in
alien atmospheres by the james webb
space telescope check it out here or in
the link below